nous concluons cette journée d'audition
en entendant les dirigeants du groupe
Altis medéia je souhaite donc la
bienvenue à Monsieur Arthur drefus
Président Directeur Général d'Altis
France à Monsieur Marc Olivier Fogiel
directeur général de BFM TV à Monsieur
Stéphane saletchou directeur général de
RMC story RMC découverte et à Monsieur
Philippe Corbet directeur de la
rédaction de BFM TV on rappellera que
votre groupe autrefois next radio TV a
été créé en 2020 en 2000 pardon par
Monsieur Alain veille et racheté en 2018
par le groupe SFR après que le CISA ait
agréé cette opération il est présent sur
le marché de la radio RMC et BFM
Business et détient trois autorisations
dém sur la TNT nationale BFM TV retenu
par le CSA le 14 décembre 2004 son
autorisation est reconduite hors appel à
candidature le 11 décembre 2019 pour une
durée de 5 ans soit jusqu'au 31 août
2025 RMC découverte retenue par le CSA
lors de l'appel à candidature du du 18
octobre 2011 son autorisation est
reconduite en rappel à candidature le 9
mars 2022 pour une durée de 5 ans
jusqu'au 11 décembre 207 et pour finir
RMC story issu du rachat en 2016 par le
groupe Altis de la chaîne numéro 23
retenu par le CSA lors de l'appel à
candidature du 18 octobre 2011 son
autorisation est reconduite hors appel à
candidature le 9 mars 2022 pour une
durée de 5 ans jusqu'au 11 décembre 2027
vousù détenez également neu chaînes
d'information émettant sur la TNT locale
le réseau BFM région que nous
connaissons bien ici Messieurs je vous
remercie madame de votre présence et du
temps que vous nous apportez pour
répondre à nos questions je vous propose
une intervention liminaire de 10 minutes
je sais pas si vous voulez souhaitez
vous répartir tout de suite la parole
entre vous faire une introduction
générale monsieur drerifus et par la
suite nous aurons donc un premier temps
de question avec le rapporteur je
donnerai ensuite la parole aux collègues
présents et puis le rapporteur aura
l'occasion de poser ses questions
complémentaires
je vous laisse la parole je vous
rappelle juste avant que si vous devez
si vous en avez nous déclarer tout
intérêt public ou privé de nature
influencer vos déclarations je vous
rappelle également que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaire impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vous invite donc
madamees messieurs à lever la main
droite et à dire je le
jure
je vous remercie monsieurfus vous avez
la
parole merci monsieur le
Président éditorialiste d'honneur de
leçon chroniqueur douteux course au buzz
machine de propagande comment fonctionne
vraiment la chaîne BFM
TV voici Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés comment le rapporteur de votre
commission a parlé de BFM dans un poste
sur le réseau social X en en début
d'après-midi nous nous présentons
aujourd'hui devant vous avec tout le
respect que nous devons à la
représentation nationale et tout le
respect que nous devons à votre
commission d'enquête nous nous
présentons devant vous avec tout le sens
des responsabilités qui est le nôtre en
tant que dirigeant de la première chaîne
d'info de France respectueux du
pluralisme ce sens des responsabilités a
conduit à accueillir neuf fois votre
rapporteur s nos antennes ces 12
derniers mois et à accueillir sur cette
ce même période 50 membres de son parti
permettez-nous donc de nous étonner en
préambule de ce préambule de ce qui
ressemble à des a prioris un préjugement
une caricature à la limite de l'insulte
passons au fond si vous le voulez bien
merci à nouveau monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés de nous recevoir
aujourd'hui cette audition est
l'occasion pour nous de partager un
bilan de notre groupe sur la TNT notre
engagement dans le paysage médiatique a
pris vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président une dimension significative en
2015 lorsque Altis est entré au capital
de NextRadio TV puis en 2018 lorsque le
CSA en a autorisé le rachat NextRadio TV
a été créé en 2000 par Alain Veil et
next radio TV a réuni des marques
puissantes des marques qui sont devenues
des références BFM et RMC et ses
déclinaisons depuis 2015 notre
engagement envers les Français n'a eu de
cesse de se renforcer nous avons
travaillé pour innover pour proposer des
contenus d'information de qualité dans
un environnement toujours plus
concurrentiel nous avons lancé vous
l'avez dit 10 chaînes locales à Paris à
Lyon à Lille à Marseille Nice Lyon
Strasbourg dans les Alpes en
Normandie nous investissons massivement
dans le numérique pour accompagner les
évolutions des usages les évolutions du
secteur notre démarche est
réfléchie elle associe médias
traditionnel et médias numérique
information nationale et information
locale télévision et radio cette
démarche nous a permis de développer ces
10 dernières années un groupe de médias
incontournable qui a vocation à
s'inscrire durablement dans le paysage
audiovisuel français pour illustrer
notre engagement en quelques chiffres et
très rapidement Altis medéia est donc le
3è groupe audiovisuel privé en
France 100 % des Français on ulter l'une
de nos antennes en 2023 c'est aussi ça
l'une de nos spécificités nous
rassemblons près de 50 millions de
téléspectateurs chaque mois Altis medéia
c'est aussi la première rédaction privée
de France avec plus de 800 journalistes
notre expertise sur l'information est
reconnue que ça soit sur l'actualité
nationale internationale économique
sportive politique sociale locale
elle est appuyée par une offre de de
documentaire et de connaissance avec RMC
découvert et RMC story nous sommes le
seul groupe dont l'offre est
exclusivement tourné vers l'information
le sport et le
documentaire nos trois chaînes TNT sont
rentables c'est aussi ça l'une des
spécificités de notre groupe ce qui nous
permet d'investir et de croître la
rentabilité est une condition pour
développer la meilleure offre pour le
public depuis 2015 grâce à notre
rentabilité nous avons recruté et
renforcé nos effectifs depuis 2015 grâce
à notre rentabilité nous avons investi
plus de 110 millions d'euros dans des
œuvres documentaires français et
européens depuis 2015 grâce à notre
rentabilité nous sommes passés de quatre
studios à une vingtaine de studio au
plus haut niveau de
technologie et la particularité du
groupe Altis media c'est de s'être
construit sans ce qu'on appelle une
chaîne mère c'est-à-dire sans pouvoir
compter sur des numéros attractifs on
avait donc pour démarrer une position de
challenger et cette position de
challenger nous a conduit à être encore
plus innovant en être encore plus agile
pour développer nos marques et devenir
chaque année davantage leader nous avons
ainsi nous avons ainsi été pionniers
dans les synergies entre nos offres télé
radio et numérique offrant une
expérience unique à notre public
l'audience de RMC est la plus jeune des
radio généralistes l'audience de BFM TV
et l'audience la plus jeune des chaînes
d'information nos contenus se démarquent
par leur dimension populaire et
fédératrice nous avons démontré notre
capacité à investir à être précurseur et
nous avons une ambition de développement
forte nous avons tenté en 2022 de
reprendre les chaînes TFX et cister bien
que ce projet est été interrompu avec
l'arrêt de la fusion TF1 M6 nous
continuons de porter nos projets avec
que ambition et volonté de
développement s'agissant de BFM TV
représenté ici par son directeur général
Marc Olivier Fogiel et son directeur de
la rédaction Philippe
Corbet nous sommes particulièrement
fiers de BFM TV la marque BFM est
devenue la marque de référence de
l'information en France cette réussite
BFMTV la doit aux femmes et aux hommes
de sa rédaction composé de plus de 400
journalistes incluant la rédaction
digitale de très grands professionnels
de tous horizons de toute origine et je
tiens ici à saluer leur travail
quotidien rigoureux grâce à eux BFM TV
est unique dans le paysage est unique
pour traiter toutes les actualités sur
tous les terrain et à destination de
tous les Français en 2023 comme les
années précédentes et comme seul sera le
cas en 2024 la chaîne a été au cœur de
tous les événements marquants que ce
soit en France ou ou à
l'international la spécificité de BFM TV
tient dans sa capacité une dans sa
capacité à produire une information
fiable une information de qualité une
information vérifiée une information
recoupée une information accessible à
tous les Français et ce dans le respect
de principes déontologiques très
affirmés qui figurent dans notre charte
de déontologie avec 50 engagements très
précis l'objectif pour BFM TV on va y R
dans quelques instants et en répondant à
vos questions et de continuer à vrai
dire à être présent partout sur tous les
terrains sur tous les supports et auprès
de tous les Français car contrairement
aux idées reçues les jeunes regardent
aussi beaucoup BFM TV s'agissant de RMC
découverte et de RMC story représenté
ici par leur directeur général Stéphane
saledochou les deux chaînes partagent
une ambition commune centrée sur
l'apport de la connaissance nous avons
concentr depuis 2018 d'importants
investissements pour fidéliser un public
autour d'une ligne éditoriale très
spécifique très identifié laissant une
très large place au documentaire nous
avons en 2023 diffusé près de 8000 heur
de documentair en sur RMC découverte et
RMC story les formats de ces chaînes
sont très ambitieux malgré des
conventions très contraignantes parmi
les plus contraignantes de la TNT on
aura aussi l'occasion d'y revenir
cet engagement sans égal et le choix de
programme
différenciant revient d'une conviction
très forte qu'il est possible de
proposer une ligne de documentaire qui
soit populaire et qui s'adresse là aussi
à tous les Français et à vrai dire cela
marche les sondages récents placent ces
deux chaînes comme les chaînes TNT
préféré des Français en synthèse nous
avons à cœur d'offrir la meilleure offre
à nos téléspectateurs et de le faire
bien sûr dans le respect du pluralisme
et de nos obl réglementairire et
conventionnelle je voudrais quand même
attirer votre attention sur quelques
points qui nous semblent cruciaux le
cadre de votre commission d'enquête
s'intéresse aux acteurs autorisés par
l'arcom qui évolue dans un cadre très
contraint le cadre le plus contrôlé
scruté sanctionné or depuis le lancement
de la TNT en 2005 le paysage a
radicalement changé la France a
radicalement changé les usages ont
radicalement changé N vies ont
radicalement
changé dans le secteur des médias il
faut être lucide deux univers coexiste
désormais l'univers ultra régulé
l'audiovisuel et l'univers non régulé ou
si peu régulé le numérique et parce que
nous sommes résolument optimistes nous
avons la conviction que l'année 2024
sera une année d'opportunité pour le
paysage audiovisuel en témoigne votre
commission d'enquête monsieur le
Président cette année 2024 sera aussi
marqué par les États généraux de
l'information cette année 2024 sera
aussi marquée par le renouvellement de
15 fréquences 15 fréquences TNT seront
remises en jeu par ailleurs des
consultations viennent d'être lancé par
le ministère de la Culture pour faire
évoluer à nouveau espérons-le la
réglementation publicitaire bref on
espère que
2024 sera une année qui permettra de
renforcer le paysage audiovisuel
français
mais pour cela il nous faut être tous
lucides et tous ambitieux sur notre
capacité à vouloir réellement le faire
changer il nous faut réviser un certain
nombre de règles inadaptées souvent le
fruit de lois soit très ancienne soit de
lois de circonstances il faut en
parallèle s'emparer enfin de la
régulation des contenus sur le sur le
numérique et tout particulièrement des
contenus d'information c'est autant une
question de société une question
d'éducation je crois que vous sortez
d'une table ronde sur les jeunes publics
qu'une question de souveraineté ce sont
des défis colossaux et votre commission
s'inscrit dans ce contexte avec à vrai
dire trois thèmes qui sont les thèmes de
votre commission l'attribution les
contenus et les contrôles des
autorisations très rapidement sur
l'attribution la procédure de de l'arcom
disons-le donne aujourd'hui d'ors et
déjà de multiples garanties comme la
consultation des parties prenantes le
contradoire le contradictoire à toutes
les étapes la possibilité de recours en
revanche le paysage capitalistique de la
TNT est aujourd'hui figé gelé
sclérosé posons-nous toutes les
questions est-il encore pertinent
d'interdire la session d'une chaîne 5
ans pendant 5 ans après l'autorisation
cette règle n'a plus vraiment de sens il
en va de même pour la règle des 49 % il
en va de même pour les seuils
plurimédiats les rapports ne manquent
pas le ministère de la Culture
l'Autorité de la concurrence l'igac
l'IGF tous les rapports vont dans le
même sens il nous faut changer
d'approche sur le contrôle des
concentrations autre exemple on parlait
des chaînes locales nous sommes
particulièrement fiers de notre projet
de développement de chaînes en en région
nous avons donc 10 chaînes locales nous
avons recruté plus de de 250 personnes
aucun groupe n'a lancé 10 chaînes
locales en aussi peu de temps 10 chaînes
tout court 10 chaînes locales encore
plus aucun groupe n'a recruté autant ces
dernières années aucun groupe n'a
recruté autant de journalistes sur les
250 personnes 200
journalistes et pourtant nous subissons
une
réglementation tout à fait inadaptée
est-il vraiment pertinent aujourd'hui
d'interdire à un groupe comme le nôtre
de pouvoir développer davantage
largement un réseau complet en région
non mais peut-être ne le savez-vous même
pas aujourd'hui un groupe comme le nôtre
ne peut pas couvrir avec ses chaînes
locales plus de 19 millions de Français
en dehors de
l'île-de-fance est-il encore pertinent
d'avoir de telles règles inadapté à
l'heure de Facebook et Youtube qui sont
comme vous le savez les premiers acteurs
de la publicité locale inadapté face au
service public France 3 est présent
partout vous le savez concernant les
contenus ensuite le financement des
programme reste au centre de tout vous
le savez également parfaitement proposer
des programmes de qualité à un coût
proposer une information indépendante de
qualité à un coût le ministère de la
Culture et l'arcom viennent de publier
une nouvelle étude montrant
confierment les les difficultés du
secteur le marché en décroissance le
marché linéaire en décroissance là
encore nous avons bien du travail et
bien du chemin à parcourir pour lever
les restrictions actuelles concernant la
publicité télé au-delà du financement le
nerf de la guerre pour les médias
audiovisuels et l'accès à leur contenus
la TNT est un moyen de diffusion
important essentiel pour une partie de
la population nous y croyons et nous
sommes candidats au renouvellement de
l'autorisation de notre fréquence mais
il est tout aussi important d'être
accessible et visible sur toutes les
plateformes l'exposition
de nos chaînes ne doit pas être pénalisé
par les technologies nouvelles les
moyens de distribution les pu les télés
connecté bref tout ce qui fait la
réalité de la consommation de la télé
aujourd'hui on parlait des chaînes
locale l'exposition des chaînes locales
est aussi une question à adresser
sérieusement on se plaint du rôle
ou de la place des
plateformes américaines dans la vie de
nos concitoyens elles sont accessibles
en un clic aujourd'hui pour accéder aux
chaînes locales c'est le parcours du
combattant le contrôle des autorisations
enfin devrait permettre de rééquilibrer
les contraintes entre les entreprises de
médiia traditionnels et les acteurs du
numérique Netflix Amazon ont toute
l'attitude pour modifier leur offre à
tout moment le cadre conventionnel
devrait permettre aux acteurs qui
s'engagent pour 15 ans sur la TNT de
pouvoir adapter plus facilement leurs
engagement en fonction de l'évolution
l'évolution des usages l'évolution des
des habitudes des consommateurs la
question du calendrier des sanctions du
régulateur qui parfois interviennent
plusieurs années après un manquement
pose enfin question il nous paraîtrait
essentiel pour une bonne régulation pour
une régulation efficace que ces
sanctions interviennent dans des délais
raisonnables pour conclure en tout cas
conclure ce propos liminire les acteurs
de la TNT sont certainement les acteurs
les plus vertueux aujourd'hui compte
tenu du cadre dans lequel ils évoluent
restriction réglementaires engagement
conventionnel charte de déontologie
comité d'éthique nous sommes ceux sur
lesquels reposeent le plus de
contraintes nous sommes ceux qui
investissons le plus dans la création
dans l'information dans la technologie
dans les hommes et les femmes nous
sommes ceux qui prenons le plus de
risque le statut quo n'est plus possible
sinon
le risque est réel que dans 10 ou 15 ans
lors d'un prochain appel à candidature
vos successeur lors d'une prochaine
commission d'enquête voit beaucoup moins
de candidats car nombreux des acteurs
actuels aurait disparu étouffé par les
règles étouffé par la fiscalité étouffé
par ce déséquilibre entre les acteurs du
numérique et les acteurs traditionnels
dans le cadre des réflexions de votre
commission d'enquête nous appelons donc
à votre attention sur la nécessité de
tenir compte de tout ce contexte dans
vos propositions et nous nous tenons
maintenant Marc Olivier Philippe
Stéphane et moi-même à votre disposition
pour répondre à toutes vos
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour ses propos liminire je
donne la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
pour un premier lot de de questions et
puis ensuite nos collègues auront la
parole et le rapporteur prendra la
parole après permettra à nos collègues
de pouvoir intervenir rapidement dans le
cadre de cette
audition merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur de votre intervention
liminaire et de ce cet impressionnant
programme de dérégulation que vous nous
proposez le législateur serura peut-être
s'en saisir ou pas quoi qu'il en soit
l'objet de notre commission d'enquête
c'est bien effectivement d'examiner les
obligations des chaînes de télévision
et à la lumière en particulier des
termes de la convention qui lit les
différentes chaînes à l'arcom et de la
candidature de chacun des groupes auprès
de l'arcom si bien que la première de
mes questions est simple quelles sont
les obligations qui lit BFM RMC à
l'arcom juste peê monsieur rapporteur je
vous demander de préciser à chaque fois
qui vous interrogez si c'est tout le
monde ou si seulement le le PDG
j'imagine monsieur Fogel pour commencer
et Monsieur sal de chou
ensuite sur la convention qui nous lit à
l'arcom comme vous le savez de faire une
information de qualité une information
généraliste et notamment économique donc
ce qu'on s'emploie à faire aujourd'hui
euh
avec une un retour de l'arcom régulier
pour nous dire que ce que nous délivrons
à chaque rapport de l'arcom est conforme
à notre
convention en ce qui concerne RMC
découverte RMC story RMC découverte à
une convention qui est la plus
compliquée la plus imposante de tout le
paysage audiovisuel français puisquelle
est concentrée sur un seul genre le
documentaire et nous devons diffuser 75
% de notre temps d'antenne consacré à
l'apport de connaissance et dans ces 75
% 60 % de documentaire et dans ces 60 %
50 % de documentaires français s'ajoute
à cela une une exposition du genre
document en première partie de soirée à
raison de 100 première partie de soirée
et là encore près du documentaire 30h de
documentaire primé par an en première
partie de soirée et sur RMC Story qui
est la chaîne des de la diversité nous
avons un certain nombre de de critères
très quantifiés nous avons 36 premières
parties de soirée par an consacré à la
diversité de la société française 15 de
ces 36 doivent être inédit télévision
jamais diffusé en France 15 autres
doivent être inédites ou inédit sur RMC
story nous devons
également c'est moins quantifié mais un
nouvel engagement auprès de d'une
exigence de parité de représentation des
minorités nous devons consacrer 10
première partie de soirée par an sur le
genre de l'ouverture sur le monde nous
avons également une obligation de
fiction et nous avons des obligations
d'accessibilité et certain nombre de
d'associations à promouvoir
merci par commodité je pense que et pour
éviter le zigzag d'une chaîne à l'autre
on va commencer par avoir un échange sur
BFM et ensuite sur le RMC si ça convient
au président très bien
rapporteur monsieur Fogiel vous nous
avez évoqué donc la convention et vous
avez précisé que la convention de BFM
évoque une information généraliste de
qualité avec un un tropisme ou un focus
économique est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser ce qui est une information de
qualité quels sont les critères d'une
information de qualité évidemment donc
une une information vérifiée recoupée
avec le respect du pluralisme qui
s'adresse à tous les publics sans parti
prix pas une chaîne d'opinion mais une
chaîne de fait avec la volonté de
s'adresser à tous les publics sur tous
les sujets et avec à chaque fois une
information qui est recoupée et qui est
validée par les
fait merci effectivement le le
pluralisme
l'équité sont des notions qui figurent
bien dans la la convention la dignité
également l'indépendance et puis la loi
évoque
l'honnêteté de
l'information est-ce que dans
l'honnêteté de l'information il y a
évidemment la question de la
hiérarchisation de l'information quels
sont les critères que qui vous
permettent de hiérarchiser les
informations que vous
diffusez
je sais pas est-ce que le micro oui
bonjour monsieur le rapporteur les
critères c'est comme dans toutes les
rédactions que ce soit d'ailleurs des
rédaction aovisuelle ou des rédactions
de presse écrite ce sont des choix fait
dans des conférences de rédaction nous
avons plusieurs conférences de rédaction
par jour et quand l'actualité évolue
entre deux conférences de rédaction le
journalisme il y a des anciens
journalistes dans cette salle d'abord
affaire de choix et parfois les choix
effectivement évoluent en fonction de
l'actualité et les critères ne sont pas
gravés dans le marbre on ne décide pas à
l'avance que nous aurons une hiérarchie
qui sera à dominante internationale ou à
dominante économique ou à dominante
politique lorsque la guerre en
Ukraine a démarré le matin du jeudi 24
février 2022 moi j'étais à l'antenne ce
matin-là je je présentais l'interview
politique ce matin-là nous avions un
invité que nous avons annulé pour tout
envoyer balayer pour 15 jours nous
n'avons pas traité la campagne
électorale pendant 15 jours alors qu'on
était en pleine élection présidentielle
et là on a fait euh une une antenne
exclusivement consacrée à
l'internationale pendant plusieurs
semaines au point d'ailleurs que nous
avions choisi quelques semaines plus
tard de ne pas diffuser le seul meeting
du candidat sortfin du président sortant
qui était candidat à ses rélections une
semaine avant le premier tour parce que
nous avions fait le choix de respecter
d'abord on avait fait un choix
rédactionnel de notre part de
privilégier la couverture sur l'Ukraine
et nous avions fait le choix puisque
nous étions contraints des règles de
temps de parole très strictes de ne pas
diffuser ce discours voilà c'est choix
là on les fait en permanence je vous
donne un exemple comme ça qui est assez
ancien parce qu'il est il permet de
comprendre quels sont les les choix que
nous avons à faire mais au quotidien
nous faisons le choix de privilégier
telle ou telle actualité en fonction de
ce qui nous semble à ce moment-là le
plus important aujourd'hui par exemple
depuis une quinzaine de jours nous
consacrons beaucoup de temps d'antenne à
au conflit agricooles mais je ne peux
pas vous dire aujourd'hui la semaine
prochaine si nous aurons une dominante
internationale économique ou
si une crise politique se déclenchera ou
si une tempête de neige empêchera des
millions de Français de se déplacer
vraiment son une multiplication
multiplicité de choix au
quotidien si bien qu'un bandeau nous
nous indiquant que Madame Karine l
mararchand apporte son soutien aux
agriculteurs c'est de l'ordre de
l'information hiérarchisée et
prioritaire carie le mararchand est une
animatrice de télévision qui anime
depuis plusieurs années maintenant sur
une chaîne grand public une émission qui
a un grand écho auprès d'un large public
qui qu'on l'aime ou qu'on l'aime pas
mais qui a notamment permis à un certain
nombre
d'agriculteurs de se faire entendre en
tout cas de représenter d'une certaine
manière la voie de l'agriculture dans
des émissions de divertissement ce qui
était pas habituel car marchand prend
position elle a fait une interview sur
RTL il me semble la semaine dernière
elle donne une interview il me semble je
me trompe pas au parisiens et décide
d'aller sur place nous diffusons ça venu
sur place je crois au même titre que
d'autres chaînes à ce moment-là ns pas
les seuls à diffuser et nous sommes sur
place et comme nous le faisons sur
d'autres événements où nous demandons un
acteur de la la sphère publique de la
société qui est sur place pour
sououtenir un mouvement social d'être en
direct avec nous nous le faisons là mais
nous l'avons fait à d'autresis sur
d'autres
situations jeais pas comparer des choses
qui sont pas comparables mais quand Aran
muskin était dans dans des
manifestations pour les retraite oui on
faisait aussi des interviews avec AR
mkin donc on avait pas prévu ce matinlà
de faire interview avec le marchant nous
savions pas qu'elle allit sur sur le sur
le mouvement sur le mouvement des des
agriculteurs il se trouve qu'elle était
là on lui a demandé si elle pouvait être
en direct avec nous elle a
accepté ça s'est fait à ce
momentlà
et je crois d'ailleurs que sa chaîne M6
diffuse avec RTL dimanche soir une
émission spéciale au sujet de
l'agriculture
merci
vous avez eu la gentillesse de préciser
que j'avais communiqué sur cette
audition en évoquant le risque d'une
course au buzz en réalité des chaînes
d'information c'est une prénotion un
préjugé peut-être qui est partagé assez
largement est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que effectivement la recherche du buzz
pour améliorer les audiences est une
tendance ou un risque de d'à peu près
toutes les chaînes d'information en
continu et j'imagine que vous considérez
cela comme un écueil et dans ces cas que
faites-vous pour éviter de sombrer dans
avec cet écueil phélippe vous a raconté
comment on tous les matins très tôt on
réalise le sommaire de ce qui est la
journée comment il est bouleversé par
les imprévus de la journée c'est
méconnaître la réalité d'une rédaction
et des 250 journalistes qui la composent
que d'imaginer que nos choix sont liés
au buzz on peut les contester nos choix
on peut les aimer 14 millions de
téléspectateurs hier semblaiit plutôt
les apprécier en tout cas regarder la
chaîne mais il y a en aucune manière une
recherche de buzz il y a l'information
euh au plus grand nombre de ce qui se
passe dans l'intérêt du dans l'intérêt
du public quand le matin en conférence
de rédaction une vingtaine de
journalistes venant d'ailleurs
précédemment de rédaction précédent euh
que que j'ai que que j'ai pu rencontrer
ailleurs pardon euh c'est un échange un
échange de points de vue tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord et puis on se décide
de ce qu'on fait ou pas dans la dans
dans la journée donc la re cherche du
buzz n en aucune manière la ligne
éditoriale de BFM TV on a des
confrontations d'idées tous les jours on
n'est pas toujours d'accord et puis
arrive à l'antenne ce qu'on pense être
l'intérêt général du public sur
l'information qui est
délivrée comment définissez-vous
précisément justement cette ligne
éditorielle de
BFM une information généraliste qui
concerne le plus grand nombre mais qui
n'est pas une information
spécialisée
ça ressemble plus à à la convention de
l'arcom strict au sensu que une ligne
éditoriale mais peut-être que je me
trompe c'est donc conforme à la
Convention de l'arcom mais c'est la
ligne éditoriale de BFM TV intéressé le
plus grand nombre sur l'actualité
quotidienne sans sous toute l'actualité
et pas pas
spécialisé si bien que le raisonnement
c'est que l' c'est l'audience qui fait
le et le
juge l'intérêt du public pas l'audience
et l'intérêt journalistique après s'il
rencontre une audience tant mieux mais
comme le disait Philippe quand par
exemple dans des mois la la ligne
éditorielle de BFM des qu'Inter
naational à travers
l'Ukraine c'est pas forcément l'audience
qu'on rencontre la plus forte à ce
moment-là il nous semble que c'est
l'intérêt du public de partager ce qui
se passe en Ukraine en envoyant une
vingtaine de journalistes sur le terrain
pendant des
mois
depuis votre prise de fonction
respective euh y a-t-il eu des émissions
des séquences qui euh ont posé problème
à vos yeux mis à part celles qui ont pu
faire l'objet de de signalement par
l'arcom et cetera mais y y a-t-il eu des
séquences ou des émissions dont vous n'z
pas n'ayez pas été simplement
satisfait malheureusement je vous
répondre que tous les jours il y a des
choses qui me satisfons pas tout à
l'heure avant de venir vous voir alors
que euh nous suivions euh les euh
différents blocages sur les euh euh
mouvements euh des agriculteurs puis euh
la conférence de presse du Premier
ministre puis euh la conférence de
presse du président de la FNSEA puis le
le le le la conférence de presse du
Président de la République à Bruxelles
euh j'ai fait modifier un ce sombre de
choses un mot ici sur un bandeau euh à
ce moment-là pourquoi est-ce que euh
pourquoi est-ce qu'il fallait à ce
moment-là un moment précis cet
après-midi montrer une image de quelques
manifestants à Bruxelles qui faisaent un
grand feu très spectaculaire mais qui ne
disa dis pas grand chose de la situation
sur place on a fait le choix par exemple
cet après-midi à ce moment-là de ne pas
diffuser cette image qui n'avait pas de
sens alors que d'autres chaînes le
faisaient on fait des choix en
permanence en permanence mais plusieurs
centaines de choix par jour et oui il y
a des choix qui sont des corrections par
rapport à des choses qui ne nous
satisfont pas mais ça j'allais vous dire
c'est le lot commun de toutes les
rédactions presse ou aisuelle c'est
d'autant plus frappant quand on est dans
une émission en direct ou quand on a 20h
de programme en direct par jour tout
n'est pas écrit à l'avance tout n'est
pas répété à l'avance et parfois
effectivement on corrige des choses mais
ça c'est le lot commun de tous les de
tous les rédaction et c'est d'autant
plus frappant quand on fait autant
d'ordre en direct par
jour qui a la responsabilité de faire
ses corrections vous monsieur Corbet
jusqu'où remonte éventuellement la
responsabilité de faire ses corrections
c'est moi qui fait les corrections parf
fois avec en discutant avec les
directeurs adjoints de de de la
rédaction il m'arrive aussi de discuter
avec Marc Olivier faiel qui est qui
notamment en conférence de rédaction le
matin où il il assiste à cette
conférence de rédaction de choix
éditoriaux parfois on n'est pas d'accord
on n'est pas d'accord encore ce matin on
avez un point de désaccord sur comment
quels angle mettre en avant sur la
journée je prends cet exemple
aujourd'hui sur le confil agricole mais
les discussions on en en Bance c'est moi
finalement qui prend la décision de
changer tel ou tel aspect si quelque
chose ne nous convient pas prendre un
exemple la semaine dernière il y a eu le
mot le jour de la préfecture à agin le
jour où le la Coordination Rurale fait
un mouvement devant la préfecture agin
je crois que c'est le mercredi il y a eu
pendant quelques minutes le mot attaquer
qui a été écrit sur le bandeau moi j'ai
fait corriger ce mot parce que je
considérais qu'il était
inexact et et je l'ai fait corriger sans
qu'on en parle avec Marc Olivier qui l'a
appris je le lendemain je sais pas enfin
plus tard le soir je va pas demander son
avis je prends cet exemple parce que des
des agriculteurs sur place nous ont
reproché d'avoir écrit ce mot à
l'antenne et ils avaient
raison eu j'envisageais plutôt des
séquences que vous n'auriez pas pu
corriger qui à postériori vous ont posé
problème est-ce que ce genre de séquence
existe ou alors vous considérez que la
gestion au quotidien vous permet
précisément de
corriger la gestion quotidien n permet
de corriger et pour répondre à votre
question précisément il y a pas des des
des séquences qui sont passées sur
l'antainne où on s'est dit ça n'aurait
pas dû être fait comme ça après il y a
des imprécisions ça arrive c'est 24h sur
24 7 jours sur scène Philippe le dit
c'est une chaîne humaine c'est un
échange permanent et donc on a cette
chance de pouvoir corriger régulièrement
si on prend un exemple de quelque chose
qui nous a pas plu récemment dans une
dans un échange un weekend d'ailleurs le
CSA nous a demandé des précisions à ce
l'arc nous a demandé des précisions à à
à ce sujet euh après la polémique euh de
Dominique de Villepin qui avait été reçu
sur LCI et qui parlait de domination une
polémique en a suivi la question de son
antisémitisme supposé était dans tous
les médias la PH dont ça a été résumé
par le journaliste en fin de semaine
lors d'une interview il disait
domination juive mot qui n'a jamais été
prononcé par Dominique de Villepin ça a
été corrigé sur l'antenne ça a été
corrigé sur le site et c'est ça en
permanence donc si précisément pour rép
à votre question ce moment-là à
l'antenne était pas un moment qui nous a
satisfait et notre responsabilité
collective et permanente et de pouvoir
aménager corriger euh ce qui ce qui s'y
passe mais globalement
évidemment l'antenne de BFM TV c'est 250
journalistes qui sont en responsabilité
et donc évidemment globalement ce qui
est produit tous les jours on estime que
cette qualité et nécessite et et on
assume évidemment le contenu de
l'antenne
le fait est que outre cette citation
faussée de Dominique de
Villepin la question de l'honnêteté a pu
être posée très récemment avec le cas de
Monsieur
Mary qui évidemment pose des problèmes
encore plus larges simplement que la
question de la qualité de l'information
mais cette ce sujet là il est traité en
interne désormais par une enquête
j'imagine est-ce que vous avez mis en
place des procédure qui vous permett de
garantir l'intégrité de votre
information j'ai eu l'occasion de
répondre dans une autre commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur l'ingérence
étrangère évidemment donc quand on veut
contourner a il y a eu un audit qui a
été fait en interne très poussé qui a pu
d'ailleurs montrer comment Rachid barkiy
avait contourné le processus qui permet
à l'antenne d'être une antenne hnet et
de qualité quand on vousut contourner un
système on y arrive toujours on a
rappelé on a estimé après un audit
poussé du groupe que notre process était
robuste était suffisamment solide après
comme dans tout système quand on veut
pouvoir le contourner on le contourne
tous les journalistes ont
été on a rappelé à tous les journalistes
quel était le process à respecter mais
le process après audit a confirmé qu'il
était suffisamment solide et qui
normalement quand on ne veut pas le
contourner ne permet pas de d'aller à
l'antenne avec une information faussée
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur avant
de vous redonner la parole nous allons
faire le tour de nos collègues selon les
demandes reçues je donne la parole dans
un premier temps à Madame Sarah legin
madame la député si vous pouvez bien
préciser à qui vous adressez votre
question c'est plus efficace
merci ma question va porter
particulièrement sur la chaîne BFM TV
mais en fait en réalité sur une chaîne
concurrente si vous me le permettez qui
est c news et sur
le le match un petit peu qu'on a pu
sentir ces derniers mois le match
d'audience avec le discours sur le fait
que l'audience de ces news se
rapprocherait de la vôtre qui aurait un
dépassement il y a eu un
dépassement pardon il y a eu un
dépassement récemment je je voulais vous
entendre sur euh les les conséquence que
ce genre d'épisode a pour vous est-ce
que ça crée une inquiétude de perdre
votre votre position de numéro 1 des des
chaînes d'info est-ce que cela suscite
des réflexions stratégiques et surtout
est-ce que vous diriez que ce genre
d'événement influence ensuite les choix
dont vous nous avez montré comment vous
les prenez dans votre chaîne je vous
remercie je je laisserai Marc Olivier
Fogel et Philippe Corbet sur sur les
choix euh quelques vérités des chiffres
euh bFM TV a été première chaîne
d'infos tous les mois l'année dernière
comme ça a été le cas les années
précédentes depuis que BFMTV et BFMTV
sur le mois de janvier qui vient de
s'écouler bFM TV a vu sa part d'audience
augmenté de 15 % entre le mois de
janvier 2023 et le mois de janvier
2024 les derniers jours en sont aussi le
les derniers jours les dernières
semaines en sont le témoignage entre 12
les 15 millions de Français sont chaque
jour devant BFM TV les dernières
semaines que ce soit pour traiter du
romanimement que ce soit pour traiter de
la crise agricole que ce soit pour
traiter des intempéries du froid les
Français se sont retrouvés sur BFM TV et
là on se parle de l'antenne broadcast si
vous me permettez cet anglicisme
traditionnel c'est sans compter sur le
leadership de BFM sur l'ensemble des
autres supports sur le digital sur les
réseaux sociaux sur son site internet
sur ces sur ces applications le
lealership de BFM TV c'est la confiance
que lui accorde les Français c'est euh
la spécificité de BFM TV c'est la place
qu'elle a pris dans le quotidien des
Français dans leur poche dans leur salon
dans leur vie de de tous les jours c'est
une spécificité une unicité de cette
marque qui est devenue le le synonyme de
l'information en France ça impose de
grandes responsabilités c'est s'adresser
à tous les Français sur tous les
terrains euh pour sur tous les sur tous
les sujets pour toutes les opinions ça
joue ce rôle
de chaîne généraliste d'information dans
un univers
concurrentiel euh très large une
concurrence traditionnelle de chaîne
d'info où chacun en réalité est dans son
couloir avec des offres éditoriales très
différentes raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui BFM TV est la seule chaîne
généraliste d'information mais la
concurrence de BFM TV ce sont aussi les
JT de 13h et de 20h de TF1 et France 2
ce sont aussi euh les JT de 1245 et de
1945 sur M6 mais ce sont aussi euh
l'information consommée sur les réseaux
sociaux ce sont aussi l'information euh
consommé sur quelque plateforme digitale
que ce soit la marque bFM TV a un
leadership a une responsabilité en tout
cas les chiffres lui confèrent la place
de première chaîne d'info de France une
place qu'elle a depuis que BFM TV et BFM
TV et les moyens que l'on met les
recrutements que l'on que l'on met les
investissements que l'on consent on
vocation a perduré et ça c'est le fruit
du travail de Marc Olivier de Philippe
et de toute la
rédaction et pour vous répondre sur le
fond de la question qui était est-ce
qu'il y a une course grosso modo à la
concurrence qui unsite TR fmtv a changé
sa ligne éditoriale et aller finalement
faire des choix qui ne seraient pas des
choix dictés
par ce que Philippe a décrit
collectif pour rebondir sur ce que
Arthur il n'y a pas de cette nécessité
puisque la réalité des chiffres est
celle décrite mais c'est encore moins la
réalité du quotidien on fait nos
programmes en fonction de ce qu'on pense
être euh la ligne éditoriale quotidienne
de BFM TV chaîne généraliste comme je
disais pluraliste et pas par rapport aux
autres merci dans l'ordre des demandes
monsieur Sébastien
Chenu merci président euh monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
messieurs les directeurs merci euh de
votre présence vous nous avez indiqué
que BFM n'était pas une chaîne d'opinion
qu'elle était attachée à un certain état
d'esprit pluraliste vous nous avez donné
quelques éléments concernant votre ligne
éditoriale on regarde ces éléments
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer euh
cette l éditoriale elle vit à travers
ses journalistes évidemment mais aussi à
travers ses chroniqueurs
àointter rémunéré pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux voire peut-être même la
totalité en ce qu'il s'agit des des
chroniqueurs
je parle pas des invités évidemment
certains sont très engagés ils assument
des engagements on y retrouve à peu près
toutes les nuances du macronisme
certains ont servi le pouvoir en place
et assument ses ses engagements on y
retrouve un certain nombre de nuances de
l'extrême gauche mélanchoniste notamment
le soir avec chronqueur chroniqueurs
bien connus mais on retrouve pas de
nuance ou de gens se réclamant se
réclamant d'un soutien aux options de
Marine Le Pen qui représente pourtant 42
% des Français alors pourquoi cet
impasse pourquoi vous avez parlé de
l'intérêt du public pourquoi n'y a-t-il
pas sur BFM de chroniqueurs qui se
revendiquent comme étant des soutiens de
Marine Le Pen et des options politiques
qu'elle présente contrairement à tous
les autres
finalement monsieur le député vous
faites notammention pour ceux qui n'ont
pas compris Madame Bachelot qui est
ancienne ministre et qui effectivement
participe je crois trois reprise à des
émissions dans la semaine une fois en
fin d'après-midi deux fois le soir dans
l'émission dans des émissions les autres
si je me trompe pas aucun d'entre eux
aucun des autres éditorialist rémunéré'
n'a eu d'engagement ou n'a été ministre
ou
député à qui faites-vous allusion parce
que j'ai
j'ai allez-y attendez je vous donne très
rapidement pour la reprise monsieur un
exemple pour donner notre réflexion par
exemple Perry colégas était élu élu
régional du MoDem majorité
présidentielle c'est un exemple j'aurais
pu parler de Pablo chaque fois je
confonds son nom de famille mais qui se
réclame d'un soutien à Monsieur
Mélenchon mais il y a même donc des élus
voyez parmi des éditorialistes
d'ailleurs c'est que si vous pouvez nous
donner la la différenciation entre
éditorialiste et invité comment voilà
comment ceci se
différencie alors il y a différentes
choses pergas n'est pas un éditorialiste
de BFM TV oui voilà donc donc pour
préciser effectivement vous avez raison
j'avais oublié de P cololgas qui
effectivement est conseiller régional du
MoDem mais qui qui intervient sur notre
antenne qui intervient sur notre antenne
également il y a un autre exemple que je
peux citer c'est l'exemple de Robert
Menard qui intervient le dimanche à 19h
sur BFM TV régulièrement qui est élu
certes divers droit mais qui avait été
soutenu je crois par votre parti pour sa
près dernières élection municipal à
bisier donc oui mais voilà mais mais
mais au fond situation de Perry Colas
c'est la situation d'un journaliste d'un
journaliste d'un journaliste chroniqueur
gastronomique qui est rédacteur en chef
à Marian et qu'on invite à ce titre là
mais vous avez raison il est aussi
conseil régional du MoDem la différence
pour répondre à monsieur le Président le
il faut distinguer plusieurs choses il y
a des éditorialistes qui sont rémunérés
par BFM TV certains
sont travaill à pleintemps et
exclusivement à BFM TV je pense par
exemple à à bandinaala qui qui ancienne
de TF1 je pense à Laurent nan qui a été
dans différentes publications autrefois
qui sont effectivement des
éditorialistes bfn TV qui ne travaillent
qu' BFMTV et puis il y a des
éditorialistes qui par ailleurs ont des
activités de presse je pense par exemple
à Bruno Judi je pense par exemple à
Christophe Barbier qui a été directeur
de l'Express on pourrait citer aussi euh
des intervenants réguliers comme comme
Pablo P Vivien de de regard on pourrait
citer TUC du aldoni de valeurs actuelles
qui eux ont une activité principale euh
et qui par ailleurs sont rémunérés euh
sur BFMTV lorsqu'ils interviennent mais
c'est aussi une manière pour nous de
nous assurer l'exclusivité entre
guillemets de leurs commentaires sur
notre chaîne c'estàd qu'ils ne vont pas
sur d'autres chaînes sauf quand ils font
la promo par exemple pour un livre ils
vont pas sur d'autres chaînes pour
participer à desémissions c'est c'est ça
la distinction voilà et puis par
ailleurs il y a des invités il y a des
invités qu'on invite pour participer au
débat public certains d'entre vous sont
invités et participent régulièrement à
des émissions sur BFM TV mais qu'on ne
rémère pas puisque les invitons et ils
peuvent refuser évidemment ça ce sont
des règles au cas par cas le fait qu'il
puisse avoir le droit d'avoir une autre
activité dans un autre média vous
regardez ça au cas par cas
oui mais mais mais mais vous ne savez
pas peut-être que certains d'entre eux
ont voté Marine Le Pen à la dernière
élection présidentielle je je ne sais
pas peut pas fairecoup beaucoup de
repris avz choisi votre question ils ont
choisi leur
réponse je ne suis pas certain que
Monsieur pil Vivien par est revendiqué
sur l'antenne son vote pour
je merci à vous je donne la parole à
Monsieur Jérôme
Gad merci monsieur le
président d'abord moi je veux ramener
ces auditions dans le cadre de l'objet
de la commission d'enquête qui est la
préparation
des des
renouvellements des attributions de de
fréquence pour les chaînes de la de la
TNT et je vais vous poser une série de
questions qui seront les mêmes à chacun
des impétrants possible parce qu'on peut
aisément Imagineer que vousedemanderez
le renouvellement de
votre de votre fréquence euh la première
question c'est dans la période récente
combien d'observations et de sanctions
éventuelles de l'arcom vous avez été
amené à recevoir sur euh l'exécution de
la convention je regardz le dernier
bilan de enfin il y en a un bilan qui
est fait chaque année par qui est fait
chaque année par par l'arcom et qui
pointe telle ou telle obligations euh
qui ne sont pas respect par exemple pour
pour les chaînes RMC RMC
story le non
respect de de d'un certain nombre
d'obligations de de de de production de
de fiction audio visuel 16,6 % de votre
temps de diffusion en dessous des 25 %
requis dans c'est c'est pour voir
comment le c'est plus un questionnement
sur comment les observations régulières
que vous fait
l'arcom euh sont suivies des faits et
plus spécifiquement celle des sanctions
que vous avez pu être amené à recevoir
euh de la part de la part de l'arcom
deuxième question que je veux vous poser
euh qui fait un peu suite aux échanges
qu'on a eu avec les comités d'éthique
enfin les comités sur euh l'honnêteté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme de euh
de l'information là aussi sur comment
vous vous euh articulez votre travail
avec on va le dire sincèrement leur leur
sentiment relatif d'impuissance et de
tous les comités on a on les a tous
entendus ils ont tous dit bon on n pas
vraiment
d'autosaisine on sait pas bien
exactement comment s'articulle les
choses avec les directions bon bref le
regard que vous portez sur ces sur ces
comités on peut avoir c'est le
législateur qui les a créé on est avec
Patrick blochche tout à l'heure on peut
peut-être se dire aussi que c'est pas
forcément bien calibré et donc voir vous
comment comment ils vous servent
euh et comme mon temps est déjà passé
rebondir un peu sur les échanges qui
viennent d'avoir lieu tout à l'heure
vous avez dit on est une chaîne
d'information et pas une chaîne
d'opinion euh c'est un débat un peu qui
va surplomber tous les autres donc
comment vous définissez euh une chaîne
d'opinion eu et par rapport au aux
questions là qu'on qu'on avait déjà
évoqué lors de précédentes auditions euh
euh qu'est-ce que vous penseriez là
c'est moins sur le renouvellement des
conventions que sur l'évolution de la
législation donc plus un cadre pour le
législateur mais de de fournir euh des
des des éléments de transparence sur
ceux de ces ces questions qui peuvent
parfois alimenter la suspicion donc il y
a la question des journalistes des
chaînes euh la question des journalistes
venant d'autres chaînes mais qui sont
rémunérés par vous la question de gens
intervenants à l'antenne qui ne sont pas
des journalistes donc pas liés par des
principes déontologiques qui peuvent
être consultants qui peuvent être
experts parfois autoproclamé enfin en
tous les cas qui sont dans une zone un
peu grise qu'est-ce que vous attenderiez
d'un d'un cadre plus formalisé de par de
transparence en disant voilà les gens
qu'on paye voilà les gens qu'on qui
viennent parce qu'ils sont invités parce
que c'est ils sont contents de de venir
je fais juste une parenthèse vous avez
parlé de Monsieur Ménard il m'est arrivé
sur votre antenne de débattre avec
Monsieur Ménard dans la dans la tranche
du dimanche soir moi je suis invité lui
il est invité aussi c'est pas un
chroniqueur rémunéré vous me répondrez
tout à l'heure mais voyez par exemple
même moi c'est pas la même situation si
je sais que je débats avec un quelqu'un
du RN sur le plateau ou de LFI ou de
n'importe quelle autre formation
politique savoir si je débats avec un un
un chroniqueur rémunéré dont je sais que
sa présence régulière est liée à la
qualité du service en toutous les cas
que vous appréciez au regard d'un
certain nombre de critères donc est-ce
qu'il faut avoir une forme de de
transparence sur ces sujets et vraiment
toute dernière question parce que c'est
intéressant vous êtes une une chaîne
avec des journalistes et on est nous
très attachés à la liberté de
l'information euh quels sont ceux des
débats qui traversent votre votre
société des journalistes et qui vous
remontent jusqu'à vous dans la période
récente et qui du coup peuvent
questionner sur justement la qualité
l'honnêteté enfin le le si on devait
prendre les 6 derniers mois ou les
derniers mois on a vu passer ici ou là
des des des articles quels sont ceux des
débats dont vous vous dites il faut
qu'on en tienne compte ça nous
interpelle sur la la manière dont on a
couvert telle ou telle information
merci euh monsieur député je ve répondre
sur les rappels à l'ordre éventuel de
l'arcom ces dernières années il y en a
pas eu pour BFM TV à part des
dépassements publicitaires de quelques
secondes comme vous le savez par heure B
FM TV peut diffuser comme les autres
chaînes 12 minutes de publicité il est
arrivé parce que le live décalé un écran
publicitaire que que ça se décale un peu
sur l'heure d'après et donc par à quatre
reprises l'année dernière ou trois
d'ailleurs nous avons été rappelés à
l'ordre parce que les écrans puitaire
dépassé de quelques secondes donc ça a
été les les retours de de l'arcom
concernant BFM
TV
non pour vous répondre monsieur le
député sur le le comité
d'éthique le comité d'éthique de BFM TV
est composé de
membres qui nous font l'honneur d'être
membres du comité d'éthique Dominique
Schnapper Anne Sainclair Anne Levade
alain Genestar Denis jambad Denis jambar
pardon le rôle défini par la loi c'est
de renforcer la liberté l'indépendance
le pluralisme au sein de nos
antennes ce qui est intéressant de noter
c'est depuis sa création le comité
d'éthique travaille se réunit
trimestriellement ou semestriellement
échange avec nous de
façon irrégulière mais fréquente et n'a
transféré aucun dossier à com en
revanche le comité d'éthique
s'autosaisit régulièrement de sujets
qu'il porte à la connaissance du groupe
des observations sur des propos déplacés
d'un chroniqueur des commentaires à la
suite d'articles de presse de polémique
de questionnement à l'article à l'ône de
débat important auquel BFM peut peut
prendre peut peut prendre sa
part le comité d'éthique a également
partagé avec nous
euh des questionnements sur légitime sur
le travail de hiérarchisation de
sélection de sujets dont parlait
Philippe Corbet tout à l'heure nous a
interrogé sur le choix de certains
invités la distinction
entre journaliste chroniqueur
éditorialiste invités consultant euh
nous a fait progresser aussi sur la mise
en image sur le fait de dater les images
de de renouveler les images et nous
challenge aussi sur les enjeux de parité
les enjeux de
diversité le aujourd'hui l'addition de
la du contrôle de l'arcom un contrôle
fort un contrôle
permanent
avec le regard du comité d'éthique nous
paraît
très adapté
à la façon dont doit fonctionner une une
une chaîne une chaîne de la TNT le
l'enjeu pour pour nous titulaire d'une
de fréquence en TNT national ce sont les
enjeux dont on s'est parlé en début en
début de en début d'audition c'est
comment donner plus de pouvoir à l'arcom
pour que l'arcom puisseavant age réguler
le secteur avec une vision étendue du
secteur en intégrant les acteurs du
numérique pour nous c'est ça le sujet
évidemment on peut toujours améliorer le
l'intervention de de tel comité
d'éthique le champ de compétence mais
l'enjeu fondamental n'est l'enjeu
fondamental n'est pas là vous avez une
question monsieur le député
sur les chaînes
d'opinion il n'y a pas selon les règles
euh qui ont présidé aux attributions de
fréquence euh il n'y a pas dans le
paysage de la TNT de chaînes d'opinion
au regard des conventions qui ont été
délivrées et les chaînes TNT utilise une
ressource publique par par ailleurs une
ressource limitée il est donc évidemment
important essentiel que les chaînes qui
ont obtenu cette
autorisation
respectent les règles les engagements
qui incombent en contrepartie de
l'obtention
de cette fréquence dans le strict
respect des
conventions merci jene la parole à
Madame céine
calvezés nous sommes très très
contraints la fois bien sûr pour les
contraes de ceux qui sont auditionnés le
fait que le rapporteur do reprendre la
parole et vous avez déjà une question
extrêmement longue parfois même trois
fois le temps mais elles sont
intéressantes pour ça qu'on les coupe
pas Madame Calvez merci monsieur le
Président en 2020 j'ai eu l'occasion
d'être missionné par le gouvernement
pour m'intéresser à la place des femmes
dans les médias en période de crise nous
étions en période covid et on avait
l'impression que les femmes
disparaissaientent ce qui m'a conduit à
m'intéresser sur les différentes
obligations qui incombent aux chaînes
notamment aussi bien en terme
quantitatif que qualitatif des
obligations aussi de pouvoir reporter
d'informer l'arcom de ce que vous pouvez
mettre en place au-delà de l'actualité
que vous allez pouvoir peut-être nous
dire sur la place des de la parité et de
la représentation des femmes à l'écran
euh quelle est aujourd'hui la capacité
des chaînes de votre groupe à être une à
assurer la représentation de la société
française j'entends par là la
représentation des diversités euh nous
avons chaque année un baromètre de la
diversité remis par l'arcom alors on
peut s'intéresser à la représentation
des handicaps on peut s'intéresser
également à la représentation des
différentes origines territoriales on
peut s'intéresser à plein de formes de
diversité comment vous vous en faites
quelque chose d'important non seulement
au regard des attendus qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les convention mais
comment aussi on pourrait aller plus
loin pour améliorer la diversité sur les
écrans parce que si la société ne s'y
retrouve pas peut-être qu'elle
abandonnera aussi vos écrans
merci
pardon je vais répondre pour RMC Story
qui est le média de la diversité et de
la diversité de la société française de
6h à 15h du lundi au vendredi nous
diffusons de l'information d' RMC sur
RMC story dont pour deux émissions parmi
ces quatre là sont incarné présentés par
deux femmes Apolline de Malherbe et et
celle de N j'ai moi l'obligation mais
j'en fais une force et un avantage sur
RMC Story c'est ma convention d'avoir
deux premières parties de soirées par
semaine incarné par des visage
représentatif de la diversité j'aurais
pu choisir des hommes j'ai choisi deux
femmes Samira Ibrahim aida twii j'ai
l'obligation sur RMC story de diffuser
un certain nombre de programmes qui vont
raconter la diversité la société
françaisise j'ai 36 premières parties de
soirées que je dois diffuser par année
j'en ai diffusé 38 cette année aussi
bien des portraits de l'otiste asperger
Paul elcat une série documentaire sur le
monde agricole et c'était il y a
quelques mois par rapport à ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui il a un documentaire
sur une immersion au sein de la
communauté Rome de Marseille donc si
vous voulez la la diversité de la
société française Rusell chaque heure
chaque jour chaque semaine sur le média
RMC
Story pour BFM TV comme vous le savez il
y a une comptabilité du en plateau de la
diversité notamment de la
parité de notre point de vue c'est
important parce que ça nous permet
d'abord de s'améliorer d'année en année
ou en tout cas d'essayer de le faire
après dans ce qu'on essaie de faire au
quotidien et comme vous le savez BFM TV
diffuse énormément de reportages en
région notamment en s'appuyant
d'ailleurs sur les chaînes locales c'est
que cette diversité dont vous parlez oou
la parité elle soit présente à travers
nos choix de reportage ce qui apparaît
moins dans la comptabilité de de ce
qu'on peut remonter notamment à l'arcom
mais en
revanche notamment dans les choix qu'on
fait là en l'occurrence de façon très
basique beaucoup de camions sont bloqués
à travers les les blocages d'agriculteur
d'aller chercher par exemple des
chauffeurs de camion qui sont des femmes
par exemple au milieu d'autres choses ça
ça fait partie au quotidien de nos choix
éditoriaux d'arbitre pour essayer de
montrer une forme de diversité de parité
à travers la façon dont on monre la
France notamment dans nos
reportag monsieur Corbet vous souhaitiez
tout à l'heure apporter un élément
complémentaire je vous laisse la parole
oui je j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
répondre monsieur le député concernant
précision sur Robert Menard Robert
Menard n'est pas rémunéré par BFM TV
quand il intervient je ne sais pas ce
qui ce qu'il en est quand il intervient
sur une autre chaîne d'information puis
qu'il n'a pas du tout de puisqu'il n'est
pas rémunéré il y a aucune caractère
d'exclusivité il n'est pas rémunéré
lorsqu'il intervient lorsque par que
nous organisons régulièrement des
débats il participe régulièrement
effectivement le dimanche à 19h il n'est
pas rémunéré et pour compléter le
complément si vous voulez bien mais
Sébastien Chenu est
parti il y a des évidemment des des des
chroniqueurs sur sur BFM TV qui ont une
sensibilité plus à l'extrême droite de
l' chiquier politique et notamment
Juliette Briance ça nous a d'ailleurs
été beaucoup reproché on assume puisque
notre devoir est justement de pouvoir
représenter l'ensemble de l' chiquier
politique et par ex ex Brien quand elle
vient sur les plateaux de BFM TV comme
d'autres chroniqueurs elle est
rémunérée merci la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe
Ballard merci président le cette
commission d'enquête porte sur
l'attribution le contenu et le contrôle
des autorisations de service de
télévision il y a peut-être une question
subsidiaire c'est- ce que dans quelques
années on pourra toujours tenir ce genre
de de commission ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le Président drefus vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
d'une part des règles actuel
incontestablement ça mérite enfin de
notre point de vue un un dépoussiérage
assez sévère puisque vous êtes toujours
soumis à des règles qui datent du siècle
dernier tout simplement et puis
peut-être plus préoccupant pour l'avenir
de l'audiovisuel de notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle moi j'ai fait un rapport
pour avis dans le cadre du PLF cette
année on a droit un petit chapitre où on
creuse un petit peu ce qu'on veut j'ai
auditionné donc des professionnel du
secteur notamment l'arcom et le
président de l'arcom Monsieur ro Olivier
mes et bah la con ion qu'on en tire
c'est que à l'heure actuelle l'arcom
peut toujours réguler notamment à
travers les services d'intérêts généraux
c'està-dire imposer au FAI de diffuser
de mettre en visibilité toutes ces
chaînes françaises donc BFM mais
également toutes les autres mais à
l'avenir avec ces téléconnectés dont
vous parliez et qui bien évidemment vont
inonder le le
marché avec le wifi on pourra se passer
des FAI donc plus de possibilité de
réguler le marché audiovisuel français
donc de Gard notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle français face à ces
mastodontes vous connaissez les noms
Netflix Amazon Disney Channel paramon et
cetera et cetera moi ma question est
simple comment voyez-vous une évolution
du cadre pour non seulement le groupe
alti BFM ou RMC story mais pour
préserver notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle française
merci merci merci monsieur le député
j'ai envie de vous retourner la question
parce que ça dépend de vous mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires ça dépend
de notre législation nationale ça dépend
de
notre réglementation communautaire
aujourd'hui les les vous le disiez
vous-même monsieur le député c'est un
enjeu de
souverereaineté les asymétries en
matière de régulation les asymétries en
matière de réglementation les asymétrie
en matière de publicité les asymétries
en matière de règles antioncentration
les les asymétri
en matière de conventionnement non
conventionnement sont plétor et sont
réunis pour
que les
acteurs anglo-saxons
ou les acteurs asiatique puisse
continuer de croître de se développer en
toute liberté et en toute puissance face
à des acteurs nationaux ou européens qui
sont eux contre
scruter contrôler sanctionner nous on
demande pas à ce que il n'y ait pas de
règle on ne demande pas à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de cadre on se demande on
demande simplement à tous participer à
la même course à la même
compétition aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
un acteur audiovisuel
français quelle que soit sa taille
quelle que soit sa puissance quel que
soit son historique quelle que soit son
audience quelle que soit sa rentabilité
et que vous allez discuter
avec le premier
créateur fournisseur et distributeur de
télé dans le monde vous êtes un 1 vous
n'avez pas un rapport de force qui vous
est favorable vous n'existez pas donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut se
donner les moyens de deux choses un de
créer une symétrie des règles de règles
donc se donner les moyens de pouvoir
contrôler acteurs ces acteurs du
ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième il faut donner les moyens aux
acteurs
audiovisuels nationaux et européens de
se renforcer
et malheureusement on a pu regretter ces
ces dernières années voir que les
tentatives de concentration du secteur
qui est l'une l'un des moyens pour
renforcer les acteurs renforcer c'est
pas
seulement un renforcement capit
capitalistique c'est aussi plus de
moyens pour investir plus de moyens pour
recruter plus de moyens pour innover
plus de moyens pour fidéliser donc le
public bref c'est l'avenir de nos de
notre industrie qui est en jeu donc nous
les nous avons un une liste et nous
avons des dizaines de rapports qui ont
été faits
par les pouvoirs publics les missions
d'inspection nous avons des dizaines de
livres blancs fait par à peu près tous
les acteurs de l'audiovisuel ces 10
dernières années
euh avec le la liste à la Prévert de
tout un tas de mesures qui ne sont pas
de la dérégulation pour reprendre
l'expression de monsieur le rapporteur
au début mais qui sont simplement de
l'équilibre visant à maintenir une
possibilité pour les acteurs nationaux
de se développer donc nous nous avons
euh nous avons le menu euh mesdames et
messieurs les députés il vous faut
composer la la
recette merci beaucoup effectivementà de
la dérégularisation il y a parfois des
règles à faire évoluer je fais partie
des députés qui poussentprès de
ministère de la Culture et de l'économie
et des finances pour qu'on revoie les
règles en matière de publicité et
notamment des domaines dit réservés donc
je pense que c'est des choses qui
peuvent être appelé à bouger à l'avenir
aussi pour bah s'adapter au marché
publicitaire tout simplement et
permettre aux médias de rester rentable
je vais à présent ouvrir l'audition
députés entre guillemets non membres de
la commission et je souhaite la
bienvenue à Nadège à baaangolie madame
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président merci à vous pour vos
disponibilités et pour la franchise de
vos réponses euh donc en fait moi j'ai
j'ai une question par rapport à un
communiqué de presse assez sévère qui
est paru le 20 décembre 2023 un
communiqué de la CGT de la SNJ Altis
multimédia donc la question s'adressera
à la fois à Monsieur drefus à Monsieur
faugiel en invitant th descuffon à venir
en plateau débattre en direct sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles hier
soir notre chaîne a siamment laissé la
place à une militante d'extrême droite
qui a multiplié les contrevérités et les
incitations à la haine raciale le
communiqué euh la conclusion était assez
sévère euh ça se terminait par vivre la
liberté d'expression non au racisme en
direct à la télé et à une heure de
grande écoute donc moi j'ai une question
à vous poser parceque vous avez évoqué
les échanges que vous avez au sein de
vos rédactions sur tous ces sujets-là
euh à la suite d'un tel communiquer
comment s'instaure en interne le
dialogue entre les syndicats la SNJ et
quelle suite vous pvez vous avez donné
d'ailleurs à ce à ce communiquer euh et
du coup deuxème question euh comment
est-ce que vous arrivez à poser les
limites entre la liberté d'expression et
d'informer
et la non contribution si je puis dire à
l'incitation à la haine raciale qui est
une obligation que vous devez que vous
devez tenir et puis dernière question
vous avez parlé du comité d'éthique
est-ce que au sein de ce commité
d'éthique il pourrait y avoir des
personnalités justement enfin un
communité d'éthique plus ouvert au-delà
des personnalités liées à la profession
de journaliste qui pourrai vous aider à
débattre de ces sujets à à vous éclairir
est-ce que c'est composé d'acteurs de la
société civile par exemple qui agissent
dans l'antiracisme ou pour le féminisme
ce ces j
là l'une des spécificités du groupe
madame la députée c'est de
d'avoir comme public comme
téléspectateur 100 % des
Français vous je coutume de dire que
vous pouvez passer 2 ans sans regarder
la première chaîne de France si vous
n'aimez pas colanta les français ne
peuvent pas passer 6 semaines sans
regarder BFM TV donc 100 % des Français
regardent BFM TV donc nous avons pour
mission de dans notre mission de chaîne
généraliste d'information de nous
adresser à tous les Français à toutes
les opinions à toutes les expériences à
toutes les expertises et nous n'avons
aucun préjugés en la
matière les seules opinions interdites
sur nos antennes sont les opinions qui
sont interdites par la loi on n'est pas
le juge des
élégances on a cette mission populaire
fédératrice de
représenter la diversité des opinions du
pays et je crois
que il n'y a pas de meilleur endroit que
l'Assemblée nationale et l'Assemblée
nationale telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
pour comprendre cette diversité des
opinions et la sérénité des débats de
votre commission et le témoignage que
queles que soient les opinions on peut
échanger euh débattre ce qui est certain
c'est que c'est fait toujours avec la
plus grande rigueur quels que soient les
invités avec avec la rigueur des
journalistes en plateau avec la rigueur
des éditorialistes en plateau avec
toujours le respect des règles du
pluralisme et sous un contrôle exigeant
continu de l'arcom et sous un regard
exigeant continu des comités d'éthique
donc nous continuerons à inviter toutes
les opinions nous l'assumerons nous
l'assumons
parce que c'est ça qui fait la force de
BFM
TV juste pour compléter sur la séquence
précise que vous mentionnez euh et
prolonger ce que dit Arthur
drefus il y a des journalistes qui sont
là face à des invités qui les recadrent
qui leur opposent des faits qui les
empêche de déborder et donc en
l'occurrence sur cette séquence qui a
été pointée du doit elle était dans le
respect de la loi rien n'a été hors la
loi merci à vous je vais redonner la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur et et
appeler dans la limite aussi de du
possible et et de la qualité des
réponses à des réponses les plus courtes
possiblebles de manière à ce que cette
fin de d'audition et toutes les
questions du rapporteur sur la plus
efficace
possible merci alors pour ce qui est de
la rigueur effectivement nous
partagerons pas forcément toujours la la
même appréciation quand monsieur Zemour
évoque le fait que les agriculteurs sont
victimes de hordes de Barbar je n'ai pas
la sensation que la régulation ou la
rigueur en face permett de rectifier le
fait que d'une part il n'y a pas deordre
qu'il n'y a pas de barbare et que les
agriculteurs n'en sont pas victimes donc
vous voyez quant à savoir si Altis
France peut se permettre de de nous
suggérer des pistes afin de défendre la
la souveraineté de notre pays c'est
possible mais peut-être que ce serait
plus cohérent si Altis France n'était
pas une société de droit luxembourgeois
il me semble mais ce sont des
observations pour ainsi dire en
l'air pour ce qui est des
obligations spécifique de de la chaîne
on a évoqué la question de l'actualité
économique
euh en réalité en
2022 voilà pour l'exercice 2022 la
chaîne a consacré 5 heur par semaine à
des programmes dédiés exclusivement à
l'information éch et financière 3 3 3 %
du temps total de diffusion bien entendu
on imagine que le sujet est traité aussi
dans les journaux et magazines
d'information considérez-vous pour
autant qu'une telle programmation soit
conforme à l'esprit des engagements pris
devant le régulateur
oui comme vous le dites vous-même
d'abord il y a des chroniques
économiques sur BFM TV régulière tous
les jours tous les matins toute toute la
journée et l'économie irrigue la chaîne
il y a qu'un voir cette semaine à à
travers le conflit des
agriculteurs l'économie c'est pas
simplement des émissions qui en seraient
dédié il y a une chaîne pour ça qui
s'appelle BFM Business mais la ligne
éditoriale de BFM TV et c'est en ce sens
qu'on est totalement conforme à l'esprit
de notre convention au-delà des
rendez-vous réguliers qui sont
d'ailleurs en augmentation puisque ces
chroniques économiques ont augmenté mais
c'est nos invités nos angles de sujet
qui fait que l'économie est présente sur
le FM TV toute la journée à vrai
dire
petite précision monsieur le rapporteur
Altis France est une société française
qui a deux pôle un pôle Télécom avec SFR
société française et Altis méia société
française merci pour revenir sur la
question des du statut des personnes qui
interviennent à l'antenne on on on va
gagner du temps puisque tout simplement
on va vous demander de nous communiquer
par écrit l'ensemble des statuts des
personnes qui interviennent
régulièrement et également leur
rémunération euh
ensuite j'aimerais évoquer la
question du statut pour le coup non pas
contractuel ou non contractuel des
personnes qui interviennent mais tout
simple mais le le le critère qui valide
leur invitation ma collègue a évoqué le
nom d'une influenceuse politique vous
avez je crois inaugurer cette catégorie
euh à la rigueur pourquoi pas elle a le
mérite de situer différemment donc je
pas forcément contre quels sont les
critères pour inviter telle ou telle
personne et quelle est la part du
témoignage que vous réservez quelle est
la part à l'expertise qu'est-ce qu'un
expert à vos yeux qu'est-ce qu'un
journaliste monsieur le rapporteur vous
posez de bonnes questions c'est les
questions qu'on se pose tous les jours
il y a et et tous les jours des débats
sur débats entre nous je peux dire sur
qui inviter qui est le meilleur expert
il y a des émissions où il y a davantage
on a on invite par exemple davantage des
experts universitaires des émissions qui
sont plus émissions de débat politique
et donc effectivement on a ces
discussions tous les jours pour
reprendre l'exemple que vous citez et et
et et c'était dans un cadre d'un débat
avec une représentante d'une association
féministe donc elle n'était pas
invitée avec une sorte de N pas en
majesté c'était dans un cadre d'un débat
avec une une représent association
féministe et je partage votre point de
vue sur le bandeau enfin sur ce qu'on
appelle le bandeau c'était une erreur de
la présenter comme cela et ne pas
indiquer plus clairement qui elle était
à quelle organisation elle appartenait
et pour rebondir à à la remarque
qu'avait faite monsieur GCH tout à
l'heure effectivement il faut et
peut-être parfois et on le fait pas
suffisamment assez et c'était un cas
précis où là on aurait dû être plus
clair dans la manière dont on l' précisé
à l'écrit en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que pour des raisons techniques
sont rentré dans le détail on l'a
présenté avec deux bandeaux différents
et dans un un bandeau il y avait
influenceuse politique virgule et
l'affiliation à son organisation et sur
un autre bandeau qui est plus petit en
taille il n'y avait que influenceuse
politique et c'était une erreur de ne
pas préciser dans cette version là du
bandeau son
affiliation
pardon juste une une petite précision
sur sous le contrôle de Marc Olivier et
de Philippe chaque jour sur BFM ce sont
plus de 25 experts qui sont sur les
plateaux on est à plus de 50 experts sur
l'ensemble des antennes du groupe
toujours chercher avec le plus grand
niveau de qualification on a pu le voir
dans des périodes récentes où
l'actualité était pour l'ensemble de nos
antennes particulièrement intense que ce
soit lors de la période du covid où BFM
a joué un rôle essentiel dans la vie des
Français lors de la guerre en Ukraine
comme le disait marcolier fog il y a
quelques instants lors de après
l'attaque terroriste du has le 7 octobre
toujours rechercher les la plus grande
expertise et le la plus grande
expérience pour
éclairer nos téléspectateurs et nos
auditeurs je rebondis sur l'exemple que
vous citez
euh un de vos je sais pas si les
chroniqueur mais une des personnes qui
qui est intervenue régulièrement sur
l'antenne de BFM après les attaques du
Hamas
euh était régulièrement présenté c'est
monsieur baloule a été régulièrement
présenté comme spécialiste de la société
israélienne ce qui a tout prendre semble
pouvoir convenir à peu près à n'importe
quel ressortissant israélien ou personne
résidante en revanche il n' pas été
précisé l'expérience le statut
particulier les liens très particuliers
qui existent entre entre monsieur Balou
et l'armée israélienne
euh euh désolé monsieur le rapporteur
c'est inexact puisque à chacune de ses
intervention ou presque a été dit à
l'antenne puisqu'il le souhaitait
d'ailleurs lui-même et que on l'a fait
qu'il était exorte-parole de Sal donc à
chacune de ses interventions le
présentateur qu'il l'interviewit
rappelait qu'il était exporte-parole de
Sal m valait donc ne pas prendre
l'interview ou l'entretien en cours
euh pour pour ce qui est de du statut
toujours cette question de des personnes
qui interviennent on évoquait la
question de la dignité au début de notre
entretien en évoquant cette
obligation le sujet de la dignité se
pose en particulier en ce qui concerne
des témoignages enfin il me semble
est-ce que vous avez récemment eu des
regrets ou des sujets sur lesquels vous
vous êtes dit en fait il faudra corriger
on ne le fera plus ou puisque la chaîne
s'améliore sans cesse euh est-ce que
vous voyez des exemples de cette
nature je vais vous donner un exemple
récent mais qui concerne euh qui qui est
un sujet qui revient régulièrement
peut-on ou pas laisser un mineur parler
euh c'est un exemple à la fois théorique
comme cela mais euh quand vous faites un
un reportage sur la rentrée scolaire ou
sur unecie de vacances il faut
effectivement avoir une liste voilà donc
nous avons renforcé les les euh comment
appon ça les les procédures les critères
ces derniers mois et nous avons
désormais un formulaire pour euh que les
journalistes puissent faire remplir s'il
faut si on n pas d'autre choix que de
filmer les enfants en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que la consigne qu'on donne
et d'ailleurs le le réflexe qu'on donne
c'est de filmer les enfants de dos ou
quand c'est arrivé d'avoir une situation
d'enfant en direct c'est arrivé pas plus
tard qu'il y a 15 jours dans un moment
où on parlait de la neige à Lille d'un
coup j'ai vu apparaître un enfant
racontant la neige à lillele ça peut
paraître anodin mais je n'avais pas la
certitude à ce moment-là que non
seulement on me disait sa mère est
d'accord mais en fait il faut que j'ai
sa mère et et son père en fait c'est
très compliqué et donc il y a je prends
cet exemple là mais ces questions là
elles arrivent régulièrement sur plein
de sujets et par exemple là-dessus c'est
un c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut
encore qu'on renforce peut-être nos
pratiques ou en tout cas qu'on soit plus
vigilant pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
situation et c'est arrivé il y a
quelques temps que un enfant qui
témoigne dont l'un des parents était
d'accord pour qu'il témoigne c'était le
après enfin il témoignait pour parler
d'une situation qui avait touché je
crois un de ses camarades victimes de
harcèlement
on avait appris après il me semble que
l'un des autres parents n'était pas
d'accord pour qu'il enfin voilà il faut
qu'on réfléchisse à ça et qu'on continue
à essayer de trouver une solution qui
soit la FA pratique au quotidien enfin
pratique en tout cas pour nos
journalistes pour qu'ils puissent
travailler comenablement et que les gens
qui qui témoignent sur l'antenne
puissent le faire en tout cas que leurs
parents quand il s'agit de mineur sans
découvrir à l'antenne que leur enfant
mineur à témoigner je prendre C
exemple quid par exemple de un
témoignage qui a été diffusé sur votre
antenne c'était pas des images de
c'était des images qui appartenaient à
votre groupe mais d'une autre chaîne et
que vous avez utilisé une jeune femme
qui a été a Tage du has qui est très
vraisemblablement si ce'est
manifestement dans une situation
post-traumatique euh et qui tient des
propos compréhensible compte tenu de son
expérience est-ce que vous considérez
que vous n'avez pas d'une certaine façon
manquer au devoir de dignité dans ce
cas non on le pense pas parce que son
témoignage était important et on pense
au contraire qu'elle était en pleine
possession de ces moyens en revanche
puisque vous prenez les exemples des
otages du Hamas la règle qu'on s'est
fixé au moment de leur libération quand
ils sont raccompagnés jusqu'à la
frontière et qu'ils sont toujours aux
mains du Hamas c'est c'est de ne pas
montrer leur visage et au contraire là
on considère que ça serait atteindre à
leur dignité ce qui n'est pas pas le cas
de toutes les chaînes et donc ce cadre
là c'est un des exemples parmi 50 autres
où on détermine ce qui est montrable ou
pas pour respecter la dignité de la
personne en l'occurrence sur le
témoignage auquel vous faites allusion
on ne pense pas du tout avoir été
atteint à sa liberté au contraire on
pense avoir alimenté de façon importante
et le le l'information et et et les
horreurs que le Hamas a commis à travers
ce que ils ont fait subir
aotage merci de votre réponse euh sur
pour revenir à la question de
l'expertise monsieur drefus évoqué le
fait queil y avait de nombreux experts
par jour est-ce que vous auriez une part
par exemple le pourcentage du nombre
d'universitaires parce que l'expertise
en soi est difficile à qualifier le
titre d'universitaire peut peut-être
nous aider est-ce que vous disposer de
ce genre de chiffre sinon vous pourrez
nous les transmettre à postériori oui on
vous on vous les transmettra on dispose
pas là pendant cette audition mais on
vous transmettra évidemment des
statistiques selon la qualité de nos
experts c'est
volontaire les maîtres senseurs ne sont
pas ce qu'on croit
euh blague à part y a-t-il justement
parmi dans la rédaction des personnes
des enfin pas dans la rédaction mais
existe-t-il a de la rédaction une liste
de personnes qui ne sont blacklisté tout
simplement parce que elles auraient
auparavant tenu des propos qui vous
aurez posé problème euh ou tout
simplement parce que leur expertise a
été contestée depuis ou tout simplement
parce qu'elles sont blacklisté et qui
décide de ce genre de chos alors vous me
donnez l'occasion monsieur le rapporteur
de tuer une rumeur ou une réputation ou
un myth il n'y a pas de liste noire de
personnes qu'on ne veut pas inviter en
revanche il y a au quotidien des choix
euh de profil des gens qu'on invite
plutôt que d'autres et donc il n'y a pas
de liste noire mais il y a des gens
qu'on invite plutôt que d'autres et ce
sont c'est les résultat de choix
quotidien il y a je sais qu'il y a
parfois des gens qui se demandent
pourquoi est-ce que alors que j'ai été
invité régulièrement je ne le suis plus
peut-être parce que parfois ils sont
moins d'actualité peut-être parce
que ils
étaient moins comment dire pertinent
lorsque nous les avions invités ça peut
arriver mais il n'y a pas de liste noire
je vous assure en tout cas s'il y en a
une la connais pas ça fait un an que je
suis à ce poste là et on l'a pas confié
et puis on peut se dire les choses je
pense qu'il ne se passe pas une journée
sans que Philippe Corbet Marc Olivier
Fogiel ou d'autres membres de la
rédaction ou moi-même nous recevions des
appels de d'hommes et de femmes
politiques de tout bord
euh parfois membres de membbres de de
l'Assemblée nous réclamons de passer à
l'antenne donc nous ne nous passons
beaucoup de temps à expliquer qu'il n'y
a pas de droit à passer à l'antenne de
BFM pas plus que sur les autres antennes
du groupe donc c'est un sport régulier
de la part de la classe politique et ce
depuis que BFM TV existe me semble-t-il
maisciv le rapporteur pourrait demander
la liste des
appels ne me tentez pas
euh un des éléments euh marquants de
l'évolution du paysage de la TNT à mes
yeux mais peut-être n'est-ce que un
effet de de l'expérience individuelle et
ça n'est pas prouvé c'est une forme
d'homogénéisation des programmes
d'homogénéité alors vous m'avez soutenu
que BFM était très singulière par
rapport aux autres chaînes néanmoins il
y a un élément qui me permet de penser
que les chaînes s'homogénéisent c'est
cette espèce de mercato dont on parle
régulièrement et le passage d'une
personnalité des médias vers une autre
chaîne peut-être que vous êtes pillé
systématiquement et que vous vous
renouvelez je vous fournis déjà une
réponse mais peut-être pas et j'aimerais
savoir sur quelle base vous recrutez les
grandes figures de de votre chaîne sur
la base de euh voilà mais qu'est-ce qui
et comment vous vivez ce mercato puisque
d'une certaine façon il doit vous porter
préjudice de temps en
temps alors c'est pas propre à une
homogénisation que vous relevez puisque
depuis que je fais ce métier
c'est-à-dire 30 ans euh ce mercato
existe et des présentateurs ou des
journalistes qui passent d'une chaîne à
l'autre c'est euh la nature même de
notre métier donc il y a aucun signe à y
voir d'un mouvement du moment euh de il
y a une forme d'homogénéisation ensuite
euh B fmtv a toujours été un vivier de
talent et le fait que des journalistes
soient appelés à évoluer ailleurs ça
fait partie des règles de ce de ce
métier donc Riat neuve sous le soleil ça
permet en interne de pousser des
nouveaux talents euh donc voilà et puis
euh de se renforcer en allant nous-même
voir en externe ce qui nous manque mais
euh là dans dans tout ça il y a rien de
très nouveau j'allais dire euh et ça
permet justement à BFM TV euh de se
renouveler donc euh je vais pas dire que
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand des gens
partent mais en tout cas ça contribue à
une réflexion permanente et à enrichir
enrichir
l'antenne une question un peu délicate
comment avez-vous été recruté vous
monsieur Fogiel
alors je sais pas en quoi elle serait
délicate mais assez simplement j'étais
donc présentateur de la tranche 18h 20h
de RTL où j'ai démarré il y a des années
avec Hervé berou qui démarrait également
à RTL avant moi donc ami de 30 ans ami
qui était mon prédécesseur avant
aujourd'hui d'avoir grimpé dans la
hiérarchie puisqu'il est patron de
l'information du groupe et donc quand il
a décidé de passer le relais la personne
à laquelle il a pensé c'était moi et
donc il m'a fait ça proposition assez
simplement et pour le rejoindre plus que
pour le poste d'ailleurs puisqu'on avait
travaillé ensemble plusieurs fois et que
j'avais ce cette envie de le retrouver
j'ai accepté ce poste là donc rien de
très délicat dans tout
ça vous voyez que je suis un béocien moi
j'ai tendance à penser que pour ce genre
de poste on lance des appels à
candidature on essaie de comparer les
profils mais si la personne qui vous a
recruté a cru que vous feriez très bien
laffire sans avoir à comparer avec qui
ce so soit directement euh ça n'était
pas délicat
on peut imaginer qu'avant de me le
proposer il avait benchmarké le marché
et penser que j'étais peut-être à tort
mais le meilleur pour le poste mais en
tout cas c'était pas le fait du prince
c'était le fait d'un grand professionnel
reconnu de la profession qui a regardé
en interne et en externe ce qui pensait
être son meilleur successeur et qui m'a
fait la proposition pas les yeux fermés
et pas pour reprendre ce qui paraît être
un sous-entendu une forme de copinage
mais plutôt une forme
de recrutement dans ce qui pensait être
la meilleure pour BFM
TV c'était une question parfaitement
candide et je me permets d'ajouter un
témoignage parce que je n'étais je
n'étais pas en fonction à l'époque où
HERV berou a recruté Marc Olivier faogel
mais quand moi j'ai pris mes fonctions
monsieur rapporteur j'ai eu l'occasion
dans les mois qui ont suivi de changer
un certain nombre de personnes du
management et en particulier tous les
patr on d'antenne à l'exception de Marc
Olivier Fogel parce que c'était
assurément le meilleur à son
poste par rapport à la question
évidemment la l'honnêteté de
l'information j'aimerais vous entendre
au sujet de
euh d'une microaaires parisque des
affaires il y en a tous les jours euh
celle des déjeunés de l'Élysée durant la
réforme des retraites certains de vos
éditorialistes je crois au moins un a
participé à à ce
déjeuner si bien que il détenait une
information on lui avait donné les
éléments de langage du Président il est
tenait de la bouche même du président et
il n'a pas cru nécessaire de préciser
que ces informations émanaient du
président que la condition pour les
obtenir était précisément de ne pas dire
que c'était du président est-ce que vous
trouvez que il n'y a pas là une entorce
à l'honnêteté de l'information monsieur
le rapporteur j'étais chef du service
politique je n'avais pas été invité à se
déjeuner à l'Élysée effectivement un
journaliste du service avait été invité
à se déjeuner à l'Élysée donc ce qu'il a
fait c'est un peu la cuisine interne
mais dans ce genre de caslà nous faisons
sorte de nous avons une boucle d'email
interne au service il a fait un comp de
rendu et je suis allé enentenne ce soir
là porter avant même que lui-même ne le
fasse dans les quelques heurs plus tard
porter ce qui avait été dit dans ce
déjeuner et contrairement à d'autres
anaines puisque j'avais entendu sur
d'autres antennes tel ou tel
éitorialiste qui participé à ce déjeuner
se plaindre effectivement de la de ceci
ou cela nous avons donné des
informations à l'antenne et je peux vous
dire que ce soirlà j'ai pas masqué le
fait que ça venait de de liser et que
c'était pas et que c'était pas et que
c'était pas ça venait pas de je ne sais
pas d'où de du Saint-Esprit donc mais
comme c'était d'utant plus simple que je
n'étais pas invité à ce et donc on
l'avait rapporté à
l'antenne pardon un témoignage je
m'autorise un témoignage personnel
puisque le même éditorialiste Benjamin
diamel prend pas le nom mais euh lors
d'un de mes passages sur votre antenne
euh nous a évoqué hors antenne alors
qu'il s'agissait de la relaxe de
Monsieur Dupont Moretti par la CJR qu'en
réalité tout Paris savait depuis 2 jours
est-ce que quand on est journaliste et
que on fait partie du tout Paris etconet
depuis 2 jours on n'a pas une forme de
responsabilité ou de devoir d'honnêteté
de faire savoir qu'on
sa le nombre de rumeurs euh que de tout
Paris croit savoir tous les jours si
l'antenne de BFM TV euh s'en faisait
l'écho nous serons rappelés à l'ORD par
l'arcom en permanence pour fausse
information concernant
l'information de la relaxe de Éric
duporetti qu'on a cherché à savoir parce
que ça faisait partie personne ne n'a pu
nous confirmer et notamment
aucune aucun parti politique présent à
la CGR don le vôre euh donc nous
n'allons pas donner à l'antenne une
rumeur infondée pas vérifiée et pas
conforme à notre Pr de vérification de
l'information si nous l'avions su nous
aurions été ravis de la donner à
l'antenne ça aait fait partie d'une
information exclusive mais nous avions
pas nous n'avions pas cette information
là peut-être de de deux petits éléments
pour éviter les ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme des mises en cause la
première sur les déjeunés pres c'est
encore une fois je parle sous le
contrôle de deux
journalistes je ce que je ne suis pas de
deux journalistes à la grande expérience
que sont Marc Olivier et Philippe me
semble-t-il l'ensemble des leaders
politiques de l'ensemble des partis y
compris le vôtre monsieur le rapporteur
font régulièrement des déjeunés presse
et font régulièrement des confidences en
off selon la formule consacré donc il y
a le même traitement pour l'ensemble des
déjeunés et des discussions off qui sont
faites ensuite sur la mise en cause d'un
des journalistes de BFM TV que vous
venez de faire je tiens à le dire et je
le tiens à le dire particulièrement
devant Marc Olivier et Philippe euh on a
la chance dans cette plus grande
rédaction de France avec 800
journalistes 800 plus grande rédaction
privées de France 800 journalistes
dont près de 400 qui contribuent à à
BFM d'avoir des journalistes de très
grande qualité de très grand talent qui
font le travail avec une un sens aigu de
l'éthique de la
responsabilité de la dignité de
l'honnêteté de l'indépendance qui sont
les trois termes que vous avez utilisé
monsieur le rapporteur tout à l'heure et
sous le contrôle d'ervé berou le
directeur de l'information c'est une
c'est un collectif constitué de
d'individualité euh remarquable et avec
euh des gens de plus ou moins grande
expérience mais chacun avec une volonté
d'informer les Français et vous citiez
Benjamin duamel il fait euh l'honneur de
BFM TV comme l'ensemble des euh
incarnations des personnalités des
journalistes qui font l'antenne de BFM
sous l'autorité de Marc Olivier et de
Philippe merci juste pour la bonne
information des nos collègues et des
personnes auditionnées la séance sera
levée à 19h45
voilà je vais devoir aller vite donc je
vais vous poser une je vais vous
indiquer une question je que vous à
laquelle vous répondrez par écrit
j'aimerais connaître la part des pigis
des titulaires et cetera puisque vous
venez nous faire l'éloge de la rédaction
la plus nombreuse de France je serais
curieux de savoir comment elle est
réellement composé et queles sont par
exemple les obligations que vous qui
sont faites à chacun de en nombre de
sujets traités par exemple et
cetera tant mieux
mais j'ai besoin de poser la question
pour avoir la
réponse je vais du coup passer peut-être
à RMC Info armc RMC story sinon on aura
pas du tout de de discussion sur ces
sujets
eu vous aviez l'obligation de diffuser
chaque Mo en première partie de soirée
au moins un puis 2 à partir de 2020
programme consacré des problématiques
économiques sociales et culturel lié à
la diversité de la société française et
favorisant l'intégration l'obligation de
proposer chaque année au moins h long
métrage provenant d'Asie d'Amérique
latine et d'Afrique la première
obligation n'a pas été respectée ou que
partiellement depuis son entrée en
vigueur en 2018 au regard de ces
manquement répéter l'arcom a adressé à
RMC story une mise en garde en 2022 puis
une mise en garde ferme en 2023 pourquoi
ne pas vous être conformé à cette
obligation plutôt et avez-vous tenu
compte de la mise en garde ferme du
régulateur pour la programmation
2023 alors je vais m'attacher à faire
une réponse courte mais précise sur ces
deux point là c'est vrai c'est
factuellement vrai le premier point nous
avons des discussions quotidiennes
hebdomadaires avec les services de
l'Ircom et il y avait à l'époque ce qui
aujourd'hui n'est plus le cas
heureusement nous avions à l'époque des
discussions des dissonances entre le
caractère
d'inédicité d'un programme selon nous et
selon l'arcom et la qualification d'un
programme qui selon nous traitait de la
diversité et qui selon l'arcom ne le
traitez pas je vous donner un exemple
dans ces deux années que vous AZ cité
nous avons diffusé un programme sur le
scandale du sang contaminé pour nous ça
participe raconter la diversité de la
société française en première partie de
soirée nous avons été requalifiés de ce
point de vue là par l'arcom plusieurs
mois après la diffusion puisque à leurs
yeux le traitement de ce documentaire là
était trop historique et passé
contemporain donc c'est l'écart qu'il y
a entre le temps de la diffusion et le
temps de la recalification et pour
répondre à votre seconde question
seconde remarque sur le cinéma euh et
pour faire encore une fois très court et
très simple même si le sujet ne l'est
pas la réalité du groupe Altis médiia et
des RMC découverte et des RMC story nous
sommes des médias du documentaire et du
magazine la fiction même si nous avons
des obligations sur RMC Story est peu
représenté diffuser h films dit
ouvertures sur le monde ça veut dire un
film chinois un film africain et cetera
et cetera en première partie de soirée
c'est certes le d'obligation de l'époque
qui n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui ça éit
transformé en 10 documentaires ouverture
sur le monde mais dans l'intérêt du
téléspectateur si moi je vais très très
concret si moi j'étais allé aller voir
des distributeurs chinois en leur disant
je vais vous prendre un film que je vais
payer une misère que je vais mettre le
15 aoû il y a personne devant la
télévision pour renseigner l'obligation
je trouve que dans le dans l'intérêt du
téléspectateur je cert je remplissis
l'obligation mais j'allais faire 0 %
d'audience alors qu'aujourd'hui en 2023
avec la convention du moment nous avons
transféré ces h cinémas du monde en 10
documentaires ouverture sur le monde
dont la moitié d'œuvres françaises ce
que nous avons même diffusé 11 prière
partie de soirée dans un genre
documentaire qui est vcéralement celui
de RMC découverte RC story donc il y a
plus de
logique
merci
pardon
pardon pour RMC découverte les
documentaires représentent annuellement
au moins 75 % du temps total de
diffusion et porte sur une grande
variété de sujets c'est votre convention
qui l'indique néanmoins en 2022 la
diffusion de documentaire a représenté
que 41,2 % du temps total de diffusion
comment expliquer et pourquoi le
régulateur d'après vous jusqu'à présent
n'a pas exprimé une sanction plus forte
que les simples rappels à l'ordre auquel
il a procédé alors si vous me permettez
Monsieur rapporteur le le le régulateur
l'arcom a procédé à des sanctions
puisque jusqu'à
2022 nous
étions loin de l'obligation de diffusion
de documentaire ce qui n'est plus le cas
depuis 2023 petite précision encore une
fois je fais très court précision la
convention jusqu'au 31 décembre 2022
nous imposer nous obliger à 75 % de
notre temps de diffusion en documentaire
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 cette
convention a évolué et nous sommes déjà
désormais obligé à hauteur de 75 % de
notre temps de diffusion qui doit
traiter de l'apport de connaissance dont
60 % de documentaire chose qu'en 2023
nous avons effectué donc la réalité de
2022 n'est plus celle de 2023 et le
rapporteur sur les années précédentes à
à opérer des
anctions merci à propos de RMC
découverte euh une émission en
particulier retient mon attention c'est
alien théorie qui est une série
documentaires pseudo scientifique
euh évidemment vous êtes sans être une
chaîne
d'information tenu par le même genre
d'obligation en matière de sérieux
d'honnêteté de l'information euh comment
pouvez-vous diffuser alienne théorie qui
manifestement prend de plein fouet
ou contredit de plein fouet toutes les
exigences de la communauté
scientifique très courte mes précisions
c'est sur RMC story al théorie pas sur
RMC découvertees euh et sur RMC story je
je je nous le diffusons en fait euh nous
le diffusons parce que ça permet aussi
de raconter la société française deenez
pas sans savoir que nous diffusons en
linéaire mais nous sommes également
diffusés sur la plateforme de streaming
RMC bfmpl et sur les réseaux sociaux
apparents afférents et ça ça ça
intéresse euh une population qui n'est
pas forcément celle qui vient en
linéaire et précision importante le
Figaro Magazine Society ont consacré
cette année des couvertures et donc des
articles à cette thématique donc on se
dit qu'on est pas complètement à côté de
la plaque quand on le propose et enfin
chiffre précis ça doit représenter si je
dis pas de bêtises 1,9 % de mon temps de
diffusion sur l'année 2023 donc c'est
c'est cert présent mais c'est plus que
marginal merci à vous messieurs je vous
remercie je propose de compléter tous
nos échanges avec les éléments qui vous
semblent utiles ceux que nous vous
demanderons également avec le
secrétariat le rapporteur a déjà fait
des demandes concernant la liste des
principaux intervenants et on dire des
chiffres sur la qualité des experts qui
sont sur les plateaux sont effectivement
des éléments utiles pour notre
commission nous étrons pas à revenir
vers vous si nous avons d'autres
questions également nos auditions sont
désormais achevées reprendront le jeudi
8 février la séance est levée